mais qu'est-il bonjour vous êtes au
tribunal de paris c'est le procès des
auteurs d'un événement qui a marqué les
esprits
absolument un événement qui avait marqué
par sa dimension symbolique puisque lors
de cette affaire plusieurs gilet jaune
s'était introduit dans la cour du
secrétariat d'état du porte parole du
gouvernement qui était à l'époque
benjamin griveaux or le procès a été
renvoyé en vous le vous le disiez vous
le suggérez et bien c'est fait les
renvoyer aux 28 et 29 octobre pourquoi
et bien parce que les avocats des
prévenus il ya cinq prévenus aujourd'hui
ont demandé son renvoi en raison de la
grève des avocats
ils ont été appuyés par les avocats de
la partie civile a une fois n'est pas
coutume c'est apparemment assez inédit
et finalement la présidente a décidé de
le rang de renvoyer le procès d'accéder
à cette demande je précise également que
ces prévenus les cinq a d'ailleurs un
seul était présent aujourd'hui ne sont
pas entrés dans la cour du secrétariat
d'état mais il risquait tout de même
sept ans de prison pour vols et
dégradations aggravées
en tout cas pour le moment et bien voilà
ils sont encore dans l'expectative
aujourd'hui étaient venus au procès
jérôme rodriguez et faouzi lellouche son
soutien à ces prévenus mais en tout cas
le dénouement n'interviendra que dans
quelques mois merci beaucoup gâté à
technique en direct du tribunal de paris